this possible prisoner exchange it comes
at an especially tense time for u.s
russia relations after more than five
months of war in ukraine holly williams
spent time with some american military
veterans who are helping train
ukrainians defend their country against
the russian military
keep your fingers straight outside the
trigger in an old quarry around 10 miles
from the front line a group of former
u.s servicemen are training ukrainian
soldiers nothing else matters unless our
bullet is going where we want it to go
many of the ukrainians only signed up
after russia's invasion and could be
headed to the front within days but some
have little experience firing a gun fire
this is a five-day course they're also
learning battlefield first aid and how
to maneuver
the lead instructor rob told us he was a
marine sergeant and comes from arkansas
but won't share his last name for
security reasons russia invaded them
they didn't ask for the fight they
didn't pick it from what i know let's
help them out
this ukrainian fighter goes by the call
sign bison the american trainers he said
may be the difference between life and
death if you want to win
the fight you you need to to be alive
the people who are not trained
they will not
last long on the battlefield
thousands of foreigners have also
reportedly taken up arms themselves in
ukraine
we drove to another location to meet a
group of soldiers who just come from the
front line and before that from all over
the world
some prefer not to show their faces for
their own safety i thought i'd come over
and see if i could land a hand
this doctor from new zealand is serving
as a medic the artillery fire is
is pretty hectic and brutal there are a
lot of concussions
blast injuries and
and so on if people are closer to an
explosion and shin comes from taiwan
telling us he was spurred to fight by
the russian military's abuses
ukraine has won hearts and minds from
around the globe in its battle against
russia's invading army for cbs morning's
holly williams in eastern ukraine